five minutes normally the players start
with 15 and there's a generous 10 second
second increment but not this time it's
all about speed all about instinct and
quick sharp calculation and he starts
with his king's pawn magnus carson
another sicilian defense for the third
time today but this time he brings out
his king's night will we see the
sicilian night off yes yes
speciality
and uh kyle one of your favorite
openings no it isn't the night off it's
the classical sicilian so maxine
vashegrav not going for his normal
strategy he's played something a bit
different he's played the classical
sicilian a few times throughout the tour
but not with success at all i remember
him losing several games to janna
pognancy to anishgiri and uh okay maxine
ratio graph he's forced the world
champion to think this is a surprise in
the opening and magnus already investing
nearly 30 seconds
it's only moved six
he's seen this position hundreds of
times before magnus but it's just the
psychological blow of maxime going away
from the opening he plays 99 of the time
yeah and it's going to come to that
decision you know should he play what
he's played before or does he just
freestyle it and do something different
i mean
magnus has faced this particular
variation oh he's made a move
he's pushed his rook pawn one square
forward and now we see a quick trade of
knights and white bishop jumping out and
uh okay this is actually
basically a transposition to the english
opening but with colors reversed and uh
both sides of castle their kings away
now white's bishop white's light squared
bishop looking very very nice i think
maximum battleground soon will try and
trade off that piece
first magnus has to get his pieces into
the game improve the white queen connect
the white rooks okay he loves this
little pawn push magnus carlsen he's
used it in every single white game today
against maxine vashti graf this b3
opening and uh white's dark square
bishop is getting ready to find a new
home that was a new move actually hadn't
really been played before it's been
studied though okay so the knight now
moving to a different
route yep that white uh that black
knight sorry is headed towards the left
side of the board to put pressure on
white's light squared bishop and yeah
for sure both players they're on their
own now neither side has studied this
position before they're
forced to just rely on pattern
recognition rely on instincts but it
definitely seems like magnus carlsen is
not switching to that blitz mentality
yet he's struggled to find the rhythm
that he normally finds in blitz chess we
saw the speed that magnus is capable of
in that video that he played against me
he needs to activate that speed now
because he spent he's over a minute down
on the clock nearly a minute and a half
down on the clock now vashti de grav
playing instantly the first 11 moves
magnus struggling to keep the pace
he's still a relatively normal position
he just needs to develop a bishop
just get your pieces into the game yeah
what else is there to think about the
question is where okay so he moves his
knight to the edge of the board so
that's a move designed to prevent the
black knight from stepping forward to
the c5 square yeah i actually think the
black knight wants to go to the other
square ivanka i think the black knight
wanted to go and put pressure on the
white's light squared bishop so magnus
he's saying okay you can move the black
knight forward but he wants to trade
uh magnus and okay the black knight
coming back to where it came from
wow okay
maxine versus the grav tacitly there
silently is offering a draw
if magnus brings the white knight back
that's the second time we've seen that
position magnus for sure will not be
happy with the draw uh in this game
but the clock times he's nearly two
minutes down on the clock now it's
worrying for magnus but he's about to
move his bishop back no he clicked off
his light square bishop i'm looking at
his screen on the computer right now
wow okay magnus indecisive well one of
the things though is that uh if you
don't retreat the knight then you're
allowing black to make
oh he has retreated the knight and the
petition position has repeated itself
okay so this is again the second time
we've seen this position so if magnus
brings his knight to the edge of the
board maxine bachelor will try and copy
no magnus doesn't want the draw he
brings his dark squad bishop out this
time a new position but this has allowed
black's knight to come to its dream
square
and the white bishop forced to run away
from the eye line of that black knight
and you mentioned that ivanka black at
some point will start pushing forward in
the center of the ball yep and well
maximum is very direct about it
makes no secret and now uh magnus aligns
his rook against the black queen yeah
but magnus having avoided that
repetition i think he's got a
disadvantage look at the black pawns
they're all marching forward white is
for sure on the back foot now look at
those black horns in the middle all on
dark squares complemented by black's
light squared bishop
i hate magnus's position i must say i
must admit that this type of scenario
where black has the extra space the more
far advanced pawns
it's quite pleasant it's quite easy to
play and he holds the key to opening up
those potential lines and i do really
like what uh maxime has just done just
connecting his pawns to make that pawn
chain
look at black's pawns they're glorious
all on dark squares in the center there
pointing like a spear towards white's
position okay so magnus he's trying to
break down the head of that spear by
pushing his pawn forward and offering a
trade black should not touch his pawns i
feel i think he just needs to allow the
trade to happen on his own terms let
white spend the time taking those pawns
off the board it's time for black to
just bring another rook into the game
and uh just keep
keep that rhythm keep that pressure maxi
bashful to grab a minute and a half up
on the clock okay he improves the
position of the black queen also very
sensible controlling some light squares
and now magnus what will he do
okay he lifts his rook up he's getting
ready to stack his rooks together on the
same line
adding some pressure maybe indirectly
towards black's position
it's getting ready for the opening
of the sea line
now vacheron graph what can he do i like
how magnus has handled the position just
the last few moves i still would take
black hair every day of the week but
magnus now he has coordinated he has put
some pressure on black's pawn center
okay
and well
that move didn't look quite nice but
didn't really address the
the plan that magnus was going to put
into operation which is doubling the
rooks now magnus is ready to play porn
takes pawn yep so okay maxine continuing
to ignore white's plans just pushing his
own pawn forward and now we're going to
see a bunch of trades
i expect that pawn to be recaptured by
white right now
is magnus hesitating is he thinking
about using his rook and taking your
pawn
that feels quite risky you're super
risky you just have to take this pawn
off the board magnus as well with less
time on the clock he needs to needs to
just
maybe keep it simple maybe he's just
considering um no he can't um pawn
tastes porn is the most uh i was
wondering about this move knight takes
but then i kind of dismissed it because
little black can maybe push the pawn
forward
so magnus he's done a bit of calculation
he spent 10 or 20 seconds there just
trying to work out the details of what
happens if black does push that seaport
forward and double attack against
white's bishop and against white's
knight if that happens we'll see more
mass trades more pieces leaving the
border i think magnus has a sneaky idea
up his sleeve i think he's going to do a
counter attack yes yes say you attack my
bishop tonight i'm going to attack your
bishop
and uh
we're going to trade everything off the
board yeah so maxim has a decision to
make he doesn't push forward he doesn't
play the most ambitious move instead he
just keeps things simple black has a
really nice protected pass pawn in the
center of the board but white pieces are
suddenly active and the evaluation bar
really suddenly likes white's position
that white knight
jumping in
trying to eliminate black's bishop if
the black bishop falls actually the
light squares around the black king
might be vulnerable and this is the move
actually
the knight jumping in because i mean how
are you going to meet that it's not easy
for maximum graf sunny i don't like the
fact that he's let this white knight
into his camp
into his territory you can't evict this
white knight and suddenly your light
squares are destined to be weak the
white bishop will come to life once the
black bishop is removed
okay suddenly pressure on maxine vasily
grav it feels like his plan of pushing
his brooks pawn there the black a pawn
he spent three moves pushing it and it
only helped white so maximum has
basically given white three free moves
over the last few turns
magnus using his blitz skills also the
clock equalizing leveling up there both
sides now around two minutes
you take white here ivanka definitely
yeah i mean knight takes bishop is such
a
such a beautiful kind of okay so the
rook steps forward
and
now magnus can eliminate that black
bishop if he wants to i think
he should go through immediately he
should do that actually because he's
winning he's meeting right okay maxine
if ashley graf is blunted if white just
takes off that black bishop from the
board
maxine vasily grav can almost resign
he's going to lose at least a piece
neither player realizes though neither
player has spotted yet that white knight
taking the black bishop wins on the spot
for why do you see that david so it's a
bit of calculation you have to look
three moves down the line but after the
white knight takes the okay magnus is
lent forward maybe he's not his now i
think he's realized if the white knight
takes the black bishop black's rook has
to take the white rook and white can
take this rook with his bishop he misses
it magnus carlsen
what okay if white took that piece with
his bishop he was just winning maybe
he's still winning but it's not so easy
anymore
what am i missing ivanka that was just
game over no that look looked really
good didn't it yep it looked really good
but maybe magnus is still in charge
white is about to push this pawn forward
and kick away that black knight once the
black knight moves white's bishop is
gonna leap into the action attacking the
black queen and then going for the black
king and there we see the bar correct
itself no longer plus eight for magnus
he missed the win
yeah
but i still think that this position is
actually fantastic for magnus here
because the threat of uh pinning and
winning the black queen is very much in
the air because the next move is going
to be pushing that pawn forward but i
mean there was a really straight forward
win let's just show this because here
white's just taken the black bishop off
the board black captured this white rook
and now magnus automatically captured
with his queen if he took the rook with
his bishop stepped back then suddenly
he's going to win a piece because this
knight is poisoned if black takes it we
see a pin you win the black queen
because of this pin this is what magnus
missed as ivanka mentioned it's still
great for him in the current position
because he's going to try and kick away
this knight later on and then use the
same idea to create a pin but
he's missed a moment and uh i think it
was just too many good options for the
world champion yeah and it's a great
atmosphere in the oslo arena and each
geary has won game one blitz game one
against team roger when the bar just
went over to
christopher duda's side in his first
blitz game against mamjaro and the bar
also all the way over to magnus carlson
side it's looking good in the oslo arena
right now
looks like this is the perfect place to
play chess it's favoring the three
players yes they all have the white
pieces which helps but
they're looking fast they're looking
confident they're looking strong so far
and uh well magnus had 50 seconds left
on the clock to make a move and he's
pushed his pawn forward and this looks
just devastating for
him
i mean the big threat is just to
move the rook to the sixth row attack
the queen and the knight the knight
can't move because the bishop will come
and pin the queen
what can maxim do here i think maxime is
going to lose the black knight is about
to drop white's queen is too active
white gave up a pawn note that
drawing the black rook forward to a weak
loose square and now as you mentioned
your banker there's too many threats
white's rook coming up to the sixth rank
with that double attack white's queen is
about to start checking that black king
on the eighth rank as well and white's
bishop ready to join in the fun at any
moment so maxine vashtagrav
he's toast
he's done for in this game okay he
pushes the pawn but this is basically
admitting that he's about to lose his
knight
it's a desperate try
so
white can now either give a check or he
could just bring his rook up as you've
advocated but okay maxim is full of
those tricks and he's not going to
die without a fight so after rook takes
yeah so now
white's king has run away black has won
the white bishop but i think black is
going to be helpless to stop a
checkmating attack against his king
white's rook can just lift itself up
it's going to be devastation on the
seventh rank right now
we've talked about it so much look at
this once you penetrate your opponent's
seventh rank you're destined to win the
game the white queen and white rook are
going to team up and trap the black king
there's no checks for black
and that means that maximum vascular
graph he leans back and he resigns about
to be checkmated
wow it's over 1.4 minus calls now in the
blitz winning game one with the white
pieces maximum vagielagra will be in a
must-win situation in blitz game two to
take it to tie breaks if he's not able
to win it magnus carlsen will be the
winner of the match sitting still by the
board magnus looking over this